cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com I gotta jump to this story
from the post millennial before I get
into the question I have for you this is
uh Ken Paxton reveals Tucker Carlson
that Biden Administration lawyers were
part of his impeachment investigation in
Texas so of course Ken Paxton
interviewed by Tucker even when I say
that he believes 2020 was fraud that's
stopping the ballot counting in Georgia
was so that they can this is what he
said he said they want to see how many
votes they needed there's a lot of
questions around the doj's involvement
in targeting Trump supporters over the
2020 election and one of the big
conversations that I hear quite a bit is
defund the FBI take away the funding for
the doj if they're going to be political
and Target Trump supporters with these
disproportionate charges you get a guy
you know he gets he gets a couple years
from burning on a police station and
then some other guy knocks over America
gets two decades
I'm curious where the conversation is
right now in Congress around defunding
these law enforcement agencies for the
disproportionate it's Central to the
last 48 hours because the McCarthy CR uh
that that we had to kill was sort of
based on the proposition that by
surrendering every fight that wasn't the
border and picking only the Border fight
that we could isolate an issue that
really you know brought it brought
Republicans like me in concert with Eric
Adams the Democrat mayor of New York uh
I and many others were unwilling to go
along with that tactic precisely because
to surrender the fight at the Department
of Justice and the FBI and the
weaponization that is occurring there
you know is is just not palatable and
it's not just that that stuff you worry
about in that constellation of problems
the federal government has doesn't just
emerge in the doj and the FBI I told you
that the homeland security bill is one
of the ones that's in this this four
Bill package that we're going to begin
to move and there's a lot of concerns
about sisa this these entities at
Homeland Security that do a lot of
domestic surveillance that are uh
evaluating political speech that is
posted on social media that are creating
threat tags around various types of of
First Amendment protected activity so
that's hard work but I'd rather do that
while looking only at the Department of
Homeland Security then do that while
looking at the Department of Homeland
Security and the post office right
so well what's uh what's your position I
mean should there be cuts to the FBI the
doj oh yeah so listen we've got a we're
way past the exacto knife with those
agencies we've got to pull out the meat
cleaver
and and I think that well I think that
really what we've got to do is return
the FBI to a law enforcement uh agency
not a an intelligence collection entity
really the communization of the FBI
altered the the perspective of the FBI
they don't look at crimes and try to
catch people committing crimes they try
to become predictive of what's going to
happen in the future and when they
become predictive and then align that
with a really left
leaning turn and then can overlay this
great fear that like the per the Maga
grandmother next door might be a
domestic terrorist that that creates The
Cauldron of weaponization I'm curious as
it has as as we switch into assuming you
switch into single subject spending
bills where Democrats will fall on a lot
of these issues because if you've got if
you've got something in there that has
to do with the program they just aren't
totally indifferent towards right I'm
sure I I you would probably know better
than me but you know I got a super chat
here saying defund to the FBI the ATF
I'm wondering where a lot of Democrats
would fall if someone said hey we want
to provide x amount of dollars to this
agency say you know the FBI CA I'd
imagine someone might just be like I
literally don't care one way or another
and could be swayed to either not
support or support it whereas if you
have an Omnibus they're going to say yes
no matter what right well interestingly
what is defining how the Democrats view
a lot of these things is abortion you
know on the on the defense
Appropriations Bill we have certain
restrictions on how money can be used so
that the Department of Defense isn't an
abortion travel agency and for that and
that alone
every Democrat will vote against the
defense spending Bill I've gone to some
of them and said like this this builds a
new 200 million dollar
s trick this brings aircraft into state
or into your community and they don't
give a if they're like they are so
um I would say driven by this abortion
issue that that takes them all off the
bill then the agriculture bill there's
this big debate about these uh these
pills that get mailed out and the fda's
kind of Regulation that is kind of gets
wrapped up into AG FDA so even even the
agriculture Bill they'll find a way to
kind of wrap in with with abortion so
here's what you do whatever whatever the
spending is cut down to in terms of some
way going to abortion break it up
further and then have like the the you
know the minor abortion funding bill
please sign it and it says this bill
allows for the funding of abortions in
your state up to x million dollars and
abolishes the Department of Education
see now now you've divorced yourself
from the single subject Paradigm now
you're playing the lock rolling game Tim
right right you've gone establishment on
me well so no but that's the point I
mean if you if if you have to collect
votes on funding for the ATF how many
Democrats are going to be very
enthusiastic about signing a bill to
provide funding to the ATF all of them
because they believe that that you know
gun violence is the great the next great
National Emergency that might justify
locking us all in our homes and and
dictating you know when how we live our
lives but and the ATF is Central to how
how to kind of uh gun scare people into
a real restriction of their Liberties
how many Republicans would be in favor
of not abolishing but defunding to any
degree the ATF I think we have a number
of Republicans who will support you know
some Cuts but let me give you an example
of what we face I had a republican stand
up and say uh one of my concerns is look
we centralize a lot of these FBI people
in Washington DC and they all become
politicians because CNN's taking them to
a Washington Nationals game and you know
ABC he's wanting to back develop a
source so they all become kind of media
politicians so we wanted less of that
going on in DC so they've got a proposal
for a 325 million dollar new facility in
in the DC area and I thought we should
not fund that we should keep them at the
J Edgar Hoover building where they
belong and a republican stood up and
said I won't support taking one dollar
off of that new FBI building because
then we will be the party of defunding
the police
well you're laughing but they they've
already used that line
that's not like a fake thing like
they're the Democrats have used that
line saying the Republicans the ones
Republicans should say yes
it I I'd be like sure well nobody thinks
that the sisa agent spying on their
Facebook page is the same as the cop who
keeps their neighborhood safe like no no
one actually believes I don't think that
while the Democrats keep saying that I
think the American people are smart
enough to appreciate that distinction
but I I just don't see that as a winning
strategy for Democrats who have
constituents who are angry with policing
in their in their in their districts in
their cities as special as it pertains
to Black lives matter to try and then
shift it to the Republicans or defunding
the police and then all you gotta do is
come up be like well you know the issue
was that we were concerned about the the
lives of our black and brown friends and
family members so yeah that's us next
question and then they're gonna be like
wait wait wait what let them give up one
of their key talking points they raise
what like 100 plus hundreds of millions
of dollars off the concept that police
were bad they don't want to give that
away shift all of their good social
justice activists under Republicans well
this is why they're seeing an erosion in
minority support among the Democrats
they're not stupid isn't that the
driving issue York absolutely well it is
and now oddly enough immigration has
become a driving issue who could have
thought look one of the greatest pieces
of political theater I have seen in my
lifetime is having Greg Abbott and
Florida sending up migrants to Blue
cities and to watch to watch the
application of the blue Mayors is beyond
belief I mean to see the mayor of
Chicago say it's inhumane the 7th of
Chicago I'm like now you see my point
I've been saying that for now for years
I I love the
uh it's just how do you describe it we
all sit here trying our best to be good
stewards of this nation good stewards of
this Earth of humanity and we
politefully and respectfully say hey on
unwatched unregulated illegal
immigrations causing problems for
everybody including the migrants and
they tell you to shut up they call you
racists they call you a bigot and then
we say okay well if you disagree then
this works out we'll send them your way
because you want to help them out and
you don't like the way we run things and
now apoplectic no single issue showed
the hypocrisy of the left than this
right when they jumped up and down and
said New York is a sanctuary City well
until you actually send them to me and
then we're not as sanctuary anymore now
we want them to hell out of here well
Adam said New York will be destroyed
that's right isn't that all because of
the right to shelter law that they have
like in New York you have a right the
government is obligated to provide you
shelter and that doesn't exist elsewhere
and so by extending socialism they
became a magnet for what now they claim
ails them yeah they tell that the tens
of thousands of homeless people I see on
my streets in Manhattan every single day
who are not being housed or owned but
the best part is that what they what
they try to do is they try to frame the
homelessness issue as an economic issue
not as an issue of mental illness or
drug abuse right because when they frame
it that way what's their ultimate goal
they want to take down capitalism but
they say look capitalism has led to this
this is why they're homeless not because
they're mentally ill which they all are
and this is what really pisses me off
because I've worked for homeless
shelters before I have dealt with the
issue of the homeless
and guess what why aren't these homeless
people in shelters why aren't they in
homes why aren't they working they don't
want to be and this is exactly what what
my experience was it's the experience of
the people that I worked with they'd say
you go up to one of these individuals
and you say how would you like to have a
room and board and the only there's like
minor restrictions you can't do drugs
they're like no never gonna happen they
want to be out on the streets these
people are often content with having
their you know little their tent and
their mattress where they can go to the
bridge and do whatever they want do
drugs or they're incapable of of
of of supporting themselves but of
course the left says it's an issue of I
I love the line they say did you know
that there are more empty houses than
homeless and I'm like sure but I mean if
you put a mentally unstable individual
who's struggling to wash themselves and
work into a house it's just going to
fall apart around them it's not going to
improve their life you're basically
saying you want to hide the problem but
Democrats will deny that it's a mental
illness or drug problem they literally
will deny it right they'll say no no
that's a small minor this is what
they'll tell you this it's a small
minority of people by the way they all
base it on this one study was done at
UCLA and the study I looked into how
they did the study how was the study
accomplished they literally walked up to
homeless people and they said are you
mentally ill no and they put that no I'm
not kidding that's how the study was
done and they quote that study all day
long yeah well I walked up to a homeless
guy and he had a bottle of red wine and
he was just chugging from it and I was
like you're doing okay man and he went
Saturday morning or something like just
mutter and muttered and said nonsensical
words his face was beat red and and I
was like like I don't know how you
helped this guy if he can't communicate
with you and I mean what was it either
Saturday or the morning it wasn't I was
hoping it was it was a weekday it was
like a Wednesday and we're like we want
to try and figure out we can help these
guys and then and don't get me wrong
I've met homeless people who are totally
of sound mind who are in hard
circumstances but the issues with those
guys is they take help almost
immediately you know I tell the story of
a guy Matt who was older and he became
homeless he's lost his job these guys
tend to accept the help instantly go to
the shelter and then they're back on
their feet very very quickly you know if
someone finds themselves homeless
chronically homeless right and then you
know where we to go up to someone and
say Hey you really do want a job you
want to get off the streets like please
help me yes we never it's problem solved
but the overall majority were people who
are just like stay away from me and then
they would go between cars and just take
a dump right in the middle there is a
solution and I thought about it a lot
and the solution is and I'm and you know
look I'm for individual rights that's a
big part of of who I am
I think we have to restitutionalize
people I think it's it's to to we have
to build hot we have to spend money I
build hospitals that are warm loving
environments where they can get
treatment and then get help and then get
food
um and we have to force them how do you
oh how do you think sorry to interrupt
yeah but how do you think we'll we'll
not make the same mistake that happened
before at least the situation like the
institution degraded to the point where
people were getting abused pretty
regularly I don't know I wasn't better
when I got it better Tech well right I
mean you know the the opportunities now
to have better oversight better
facilities look at the way prisons have
changed in their construction and how
inmates are you know able to be uh cared
for and observed with fewer staff more
cameras AI technology sensor technology
Communications technology different
types of displays that you have
available so I think that I think that
we're not going to go back to like the
1960s and 70s version of institution
yeah we're not going back to that world
world we could do this in a more
modernized way yeah we could use the
solid it's a solvable problem webcams if
you let people that are in the
institution communicate with their
families they won't feel so isolated
that's a big part of it yeah you can
even have somebody like a therapist
watching the call if you want and they
can be taking notes and they know
they're being watched depending on the
diagnosis sure sure yes it'd be like a
privilege you could earn from good
behavior I think I think the default
should be that you have free
communications I think that should
happen in jail personally free
activities you can come and go from room
as you please and then depending on the
severity of the the suffering of the
individual like if they're if they're
prone to uh like delusions and then
violence then we say okay now we're
going to detain you because you're a
threat to others but for a lot of these
people who are
just let's just say they're not capable
of supporting themselves due to a lack
of cognitive capabilities well you can
come and go from your room as you please
you're a nice individual you're not
causing anyone harm here's board games
here's food but you're off the streets
you're not covered in filth you're not
doing drugs you're not drinking you're
not crapping on the ground and we're
actually trying to help it's more Humane
I know it's it it is laughably absurd
the idea is leave them out to crap in
the streets and that's what San
Francisco is no these people are not
being helped by being left to roam on
their own of their own devices and just
live in the corner of buildings and in
their own ways it's dangerous for other
people too having to step over those
people and if they get hungry if one guy
snaps and he's got a sharp piece of
glass on him you know you gotta are they
just doing drugs man did you you would
think it's a nonpartisan issue but the
reality is we're talking about wet
juices before they use it they want it
because they use it as a wedge issue say
look at the the how horrible or economic
system is today I want to jump to this
story why wouldn't it work as a wedge
issue for like as a Florida man I don't
really understand the homelessness thing
because we have a less of a societal
tolerance for it you know we just tell
people you you can't set up encampments
I mean we do what we can as a state to
be compassionate like you say for those
who want help but you don't see these
things in Florida like you see them in
LA or New York and like I I don't
understand why the argument isn't more
compelling like hey I'll get these I'll
get these people to leave and quality of
life will be better is that too
simplistic I mean they're just we're
just shuffling them off somewhere else I
think we have to find a more sustainable
solution thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time